I have completely unsurprising.
Shocking news for you today, a 50 year study
of tax cuts has determined that when you give
the very rich tax cuts, things don't trickle
down and inequality actually gets worse.
Now, if you understand economics at all, you
would say, David, how is this even a story?
But there's a large part of this country that
still thinks you give tax cuts to the rich,
money trickles down and it reduces inequality
and everything's good.
This is a paper from the London School of
Economics and King's College, London.
And it looked at 50 years of tax cuts for
the wealthy across 18 different countries.
And they evaluated claims like trickle down
tax cuts for the rich, trickle down and help
the economy or cutting taxes on the rich reduces
inequality.
And what they found is that cutting taxes
on the rich increases inequality, gives the
rich more money with almost nothing trickling
down below overall, increases inequality and
doesn't improve economic performance.
Overall, it doesn't lead to economic growth.
It doesn't lead to employment growth.
It just causes higher income inequality.
And one of the things that is important to
understand about this is that there are always
going to be let's divide this up into two
ways.
I think that for a lot of just average people
who don't study economics, this idea was always
a hard sell, I think, to just normal folks
who have not been radicalized to fall for
trickle down economics.
If you go to normal people who just work a
job and don't think too much about it, and
you say, hey, if we give tax cuts to the really
rich, do you think it helps you?
You go to a Laundromat owner or a hardware
store owner or a teacher and you say, hey,
we're giving billionaires and people with
over 50 million in assets, we're giving them
a tax cut.
Do you think this will help you?
I think that's always been a hard sell for
the average person.
But there is an entire movement that is based
around paying people at think tanks and other
places to claim that tax cuts for the rich
are going to help everybody in some way.
And the assumption that really fails is that
when you cut taxes for the rich, more people
are hired and it fails for a number of different
reasons.
First of all, most of the money doesn't even
enter the ecosystem of where it would affect
hiring because rich people have a much higher
savings rate than poor people.
If you give a poor person a five percent reduction
in their tax taxes, they're almost certainly
going to spend all of that money.
If you give a really, really rich person a
five percent reduction in their taxes, they're
going to save most of that money because they're
not counting on that money to live.
And as a result, because the money is just
being saved, it's not being spent by rich
people in a way that creates a need for more
employees or a need to pay employees more
money.
Number two, even the money that the rich do
spend out of business, only part of that goes
to wages and mostly that additional spending
that the rich do goes to profits.
And part of the hard costs of the things that
they are buying.
The driver of hiring, we know, is demand.
It's not labor supply.
And this is often an argument that's missing
when talking about illegal immigration or
immigration in general, the argument that
we hear goes they come here legally or illegally.
Doesn't our economic argument, it doesn't
matter.
They take our jobs and because they increase
the supply of labor, wages go down.
It's basic economics.
They say you bring in a lot more people looking
for work and companies can pay less and they're
stealing jobs and lowering wages.
Well, remember, wages are only part of the
cost of a good or service.
And remember that all of those immigrants
in your community, legal or illegal immigrants,
they also buy stuff.
They also rent apartments, they also buy food,
they go to restaurants.
So what's missing from this overly simplistic
analysis is that when you have immigrants
come in looking for work, it's a huge increase
to demand because you have more people demanding
products and services, which under the same
simple economic argument would mean businesses
can raise prices and make more money.
Right.
And people only talk about supply of labor
to argue against immigration and ignore the
other side of that, which is the demand increase,
which is good for businesses.
And this is all been demonstrated academically
by countless economic papers.
So what's missing you anybody surprised to
get back to the main article?
Anybody surprised that over 50 years in 18
different countries, cutting taxes for the
rich didn't trickle down, but it just increased
income inequality.
You lack and I'm not saying this pejoratively,
it sounds like you just lack a more holistic
macroeconomic understanding.
Of course, cutting taxes for the rich didn't
stimulate the economy in the way that some
of these supply siders think.
Let me know your thoughts, but a completely
unsurprising result.